hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
i'm a national master here at the st
louis chess club and this
is the first week we are both in person
and online so rather than from the
studio i'm actually coming live
from the former kingside diner right by
the chess club if you're in the st
louis area stop watching online come out
to the chess club right now
and join us in the classroom so we have
a live audience tonight so thank you
guys for
for showing up glad to have everybody
here
um and what i want to talk about tonight
is tactics
so tactics are a pretty hot topic for
chess improvement uh if you ask strong
players a lot of times they will tell
you the way to improve
is to get better at tactics to
understand tactics better
but i've said in previous classes that
that isn't always enough
information a lot of people study
tactics and kind of the wrong way
in a way where they're not going to get
the most out of it and some people have
different problems with tactics than
other people so tonight what i want to
do
i want to break down different kinds of
tactics
different ways of thinking about tactics
and tell you guys how you can work to
improve each one
so to start with i have a position up on
the board and we're just going to do a
couple tactics
just for fun just to warm up before we
delve into uh
the nitty gritty so this mission is
white to move the in-person audience i
think has been dying to give me the
answer
for the past couple minutes so uh who
thinks
they have a solution all right eric
thinks he has it caleb
in the back seven all right uh so if
you're watching on youtube and you
haven't had enough time to think go
ahead and pause for a second but brian
what do you think
i like b7 yeah rook b7
is exactly right and so uh rook b7 the
idea
is to of course pin the queen to the
king if
black were to naively capture this rook
our idea is the the follow up with this
fork knight takes d6
attacking the king and the queen this
move knight d7
might be a little bit tougher but
there's a variety of good moves here
who thinks they have the best one
eric rook
takes d7 are you sure
all right he's sure so queen takes d7
and it's the the exact same idea as last
time
knight takes e5 is the critical move
here to win the game
this time taking advantage of a a pin on
the d-pawn as well
so well done for the first warm-up uh
let's get another warm-up tactic before
we start talking
for for serious stuff so black to move
in this position and let's just try to
solve this tactic
like we would any other take a moment to
think about it
can i ask your name
jacob all right do you think you have
something jacob i saw you thinking about
it
not yet take your time take your time
and the class is stumped
okay eric thinks he has it yeah
um
yeah so that's exactly right so eric
came up with this move rook b2
uh threatening this pawn on g2 with
checkmate so white's gonna have to
defend this somehow
the only real way that you can defend it
is by interfering with this bishop
but then this guy is going to fall on d6
but is that the end of the story is
there more to this puzzle
yeah and that's exactly right so this e5
move is a little bit tricky at the end
of the story but eric was saying
you can just capture it's not back rank
mate
uh because we can play wait what can we
play
hold on we can play rook b8 that's right
forgot about that line and he was saying
bishop g3 doesn't think works
because well there's a variety of moves
i think even queen c6 would be
an option there counter-attacking on uh
on g2 so what we just did were just two
normal tactics
and we kind of solved them i think we
would all agree in normal way this is
just how people solve tactics
we sit there we think about them we see
the answer
and then we move on um and when people
say they're going to work on tactics a
lot of times
that's all they do they they see a
tactic they think about it
when they think they have the answer
they go for it and then they see if they
were right
and then they move on and that is
definitely one way to do tactics you
will get better
at tactics by doing them like this but i
think it's a little bit more helpful
to break them down a little bit more
into their different elements and figure
out really where your weak spots are and
where your strong spots are
so uh the first part of tactics that i
like to talk about
are the different kinds of patterns
sometimes what you need to work on is
just your pattern recognition
in general recognizing things like
this is a pin for example recognizing
that this is a pin
recognizing this pattern of checkmate on
g2 that's what some people need to work
on
so i want to do one uh sort of pattern
heavy
one that features a lot of patterns and
this is
the puzzle i like to show for that so
we're gonna focus on this puzzle with
the idea
of training the different patterns and
then
after we solve the puzzle we're going to
review it a little bit
and that review is where i think a lot
of
the learning takes place with tactics
so it's white to move in this position
and there should be a couple things that
stand out to you
but take a moment and see if you can
identify some of the themes
hmm
all right who thinks they have a
candidate move couple candidate moves
some ideas don't have to have the whole
answer
but some moves probably stick out
jacob i don't think i've heard from you
sanders there's two jacobs in the
audience um
i'm just the first thing i'm looking at
just because i feel like it has to be
right
but it's some knight g5 idea yeah so
probably ideas centering around this h
file are going to be sticking out ideas
involving bringing the knight to g5
maybe ideas of bringing this bishop into
h7
are things that we're thinking about
right and how are we arriving
at that conclusion well it's down to our
pattern recognition right you don't find
knight g5 because you were a great
calculator a great visualizer this is
one of those puzzles that's going to be
solved
by recognizing familiar patterns now not
every tactic is going to be like that
but some tactics are
so after knight g5 what are some more
familiar patterns
that we're thinking about
looking for ways to bring this queen
into the king's side and deliver a
checkmate
so now that we know what kind of
patterns we're looking for
now we're going to try to visualize and
calculate
to find the specifics so these are the
ideas that should be floating around
now step two is bringing down the hammer
and i'm going to refresh my youtube chat
i think it was a little broken there
they are
yeah the youtube chat also likes this
knight g5 move but they don't have much
else worked out it looks like
not yet at least
i'm just trying to see what happens
yeah so that's relevant as well right
knight g5 black isn't forced to capture
it so
that's another critical line
as ben feingold would say it's not
checkers they don't have to take
all right do you have the full thing
eric yeah does your line end in
checkmate
one of them does all right let's hear it
what do you got
knight g5
there you go eric with the full and
complete answer so he was saying knight
g5 is the first move
and so this is a move that no matter how
good at visualizing you are
you know if you don't consider this move
in the first place then you're not going
to solve the tactic
and so this is what i mean when it's
useful to break tactics down
into their parts some people this is the
part they struggle with they're just not
searching
broadly enough to find a move like
knight g5 they don't know the patterns
well enough
and so even if they can visualize all
the way to the end of the line
if they don't consider the move knight
g5 then they're not going to be able to
solve the puzzle
so knight g5 and the point now is as
eric said
if black were to ignore our threat and
just move the queen out of the way
then knight h7 is simple enough we're
going to be winning an exchange
on the f8 square this rook is just
trapped can't move the rook
and then the fun line is h takes
on g5 and eric pointed out now
that we are able to deliver this check
on h7 very important
that we don't play the move queen h5
because black would be able to just
block with queen h6
so he goes bishop h7 we bring the king
to
uh we bring the king to h8
now bishop f5 would be pretty good
winning a queen for a rook after queen
h6
but eric found the best line with bishop
g6
king g8 rook h8 drawing the king vh file
again
and now queen h5 with check and queen h7
ending it with checkmate so every part
of that line
uh there were you know some moves that
seemed obvious and then some moves that
were a little bit counter-intuitive like
bishop g6 for example
if you're not familiar with this pattern
of the queen on h7
to its core you're probably not really
thinking about bishop g6 too seriously
now in this case it doesn't matter you
can just win a queen
and be much better but i would prefer to
end the game on the spot with checkmate
obviously in some positions you're not
going to have the easy out with bishop
f5 winning a queen sometimes you'll have
to find
this uh this continuation here so this
is what i like to call a very pattern
heavy
puzzle let's identify some of the
patterns so knight g5
in a sense is a clearance we're clearing
the way for
uh our queen to come into the uh to come
into play
we're distracting this pawn off of h6 we
are sacrificing to attract the king to
an inferior square oh well not yet
actually we're giving this check first
we are uh interfering with the queen's
access to age
six we are attracting the queen to a bad
square
and lastly of course this is a common
mating pattern so all these building
blocks of tactics come together
to result in this uh this puzzle this
checkmate
and for a lot of people this is the part
that they really struggle with
you can train calculation until the cows
come home
but if you're not recognizing the
patterns
you're not going to be able to solve
puzzles like like these
so who here has any ideas for how you
can train
your pattern recognition like this how
can we solve tactics
to to to train our pattern recognition
does anybody have
experience doing that there's a couple
things i want to touch on here a couple
training methods yeah jacob i know that
like certain
uh
yeah so what jacob just said is websites
like leeches.com they will often let you
sort
by tactical motifs so for example this
position
combined many many many different motifs
into one but if you're noticing you're
not really seeing
a certain motif like pins for example
you just they don't make sense to you
you can definitely sort tactics buy pins
on these websites
um but any any other ways any training
ideas before i give you
my my takes i'm curious what else is out
there what else is out there
caleb what do you do to train your
pattern recognition
uh we have another caleb in the class
and he said he just sits there and does
tactics for hours but it doesn't seem to
be working
um so there there's a couple different
ways that i like to uh
to go through this and for this idea of
broadening your search as wide as
possible
i think the really important key is to
go
through uh every relevant line
in the tactic in depth whenever you do a
tactic you should go back through it
and check pretty much every relevant
line you can think of because you'll
notice
different themes are appearing in these
puzzles just the main line isn't enough
to exploit the theme
and the big one that i'm surprised
didn't get uh didn't get a shout out
in this particular audience is the
woodpecker method
everybody loves the woodpecker method um
for those of you unfamiliar the
woodpecker method is the latest
uh in a series of books on tactics
that's uh really expound on the
benefits of repetition so the woodpecker
method is you just you keep
slamming your head into a tree until
until it makes sense
so what does that involve that involves
doing the same set of tactics over and
over again
so you sort of absorb them into your
subconscious you're not
necessarily even having to think about
them by the last time you're repeating
them
and that's one way to go about it but i
wanted to highlight a website that a
friend of mine
actually has been developing and that is
this website called
chessbolt i think this is a really
useful tool
for starting to recognize puzzle themes
so if i can just click on a puzzle here
we'll go through it let's i guess solve
it together since
we're here so this one is black to play
uh
i haven't prepared this puzzle it's just
from this this website so take a second
see if you can find uh
find a solution here
well eric thinks he already has it
all right what's your solution eric
so eric thinks we should bring in the
rooks to the second rank the trainer
seems to agree
and then he said probably mating pretty
soon so go ahead
and crickets crickets in the audience
got to be careful
i have an idea think you got something
jacob
it doesn't have to be right we're just
talking ideas
okay so rook h1 i don't think is gonna
quite do it um
we would draw the the king back to the
h1 square
but the king could just capture so we're
not quite
getting our checkmate because the square
is covered
and i think the chat room has a good
idea here
eg2 apparently was good enough according
to this website but it likes king e4 a
bit more
i actually like the move rook h3 but i
think king e4 is
is gonna be good enough um and how do we
finish him off here
bishop takes d4 not bishop takes d4 f3
makes sense okay so we go f3 and then
the follow-up i'm sure
is rook g2 and rook h1 so how is this
any different than a normal tactics
website
well the idea if i can scroll down
is that it goes through all of the
tactical themes
in the position and it goes through all
of the relevant variations that it can
pick out
and so it's really good for helping to
identify uh some of these themes
so why was king e4 correct by the way
well king e4
seems to have attacked this rook on d3
and it's a little bit
uh overloaded according to the website
if the rook were to move sideways
it's saying that the d4 pawn is hanging
so bishop takes d4
would be important um and
if it comes down then it's not defending
f3
so we saw this line with f3 in the
puzzle but if the rook were to move away
then bishop takes d4 is also important
um and here i think it's going to show
you that line
so yeah if we take the rook we get
checked we can block
and we're threatening bishop takes d4
queening
checkmating everything and so i just
wanted to give this website a little bit
of a shout out
for this type of pattern recognition if
you're finding yourself you don't really
understand the different patterns
and you're not certain you're seeing the
full lines in your puzzles
i wanted to shout this out as as one
tool
i think the woodpecker method it's got
its critics it's got its
uh die hard fans i do think that's a
good way of training this type of thing
as well
it really helps you you know learn those
patterns
uh deeply and fully but let's move back
to my early chest study here
if i can uh switch back and forth a
little bit
and this is one area where people
struggle they struggle with pattern
recognition but i want to move on to
another area
where people tend to struggle and that
is with visualization
so who knows what i mean by
visualization
eric knows jacob knows do you know jacob
have you heard this word
nope so what does it mean to visualize
something well
it means you don't see it on the board
you have to see it in your head you're
calculating
in your head that's what visualization
is
so for example there's a little bit of
visualization in this tactic
right you have to see all this crazy
stuff happening ahead of time
in your head but it's mostly focused on
these checkmating patterns these
different tactical motifs
so what do i like to do for training
visualization there's a couple things
uh one which is an old favorite is to
study
end games end game studies are very
heavy
on visualization and calculating
very very far in advance now why is this
the case well
end game studies tend to be positions
with very few pieces
it's what makes them end games and since
there are not very many pieces on the
board
usually you can go many many many many
moves in advance
so i have on your screen a rather
difficult end game study it's black to
move
in this position um not
totally normal for a study but it'll
it'll get the job done
uh black to move and you have to find
the best line
now if you're a real die hard at home i
would recommend
you know pausing your video and taking
like 20 minutes to try to work this one
out
we're not going to do that in the class
for obvious reasons
but we will still work through through
the whole thing so take a minute or two
and see if you can figure out what's
going on and we'll kind of solve it
in sections take a minute or two to
think though
so yeah that last website the chat is
asking is chessbolt.org
and maybe we'll link it in the
description as well
i can take a hit ben simon
message received he says okay
yeah so the chat sees a tactical idea
right off the bat
using that pattern recognition they see
an idea but we have to calculate a
little further
and i won't spoil it for the in-person
audience
the chad is asking me how to be a
grandmaster
i we're we're trying to get to 2000 okay
2000 first
yeah what do you think jacob
yes so this is the idea that the youtube
chat
actually came up with as well it's a
it's a pretty strong idea
um what's our point what's our point if
um
white were to capture this pawn for
example
ah i'm learning oh god
sorry just just trying to mute the
laptop here i'm getting some kind of
notification but we're there now
yes yes so we take with the knight
and if white takes back
yeah and you just get to queen uh
unfortunately it's
not quite as simple as that
uh if we were to play f3 right away i
think white can actually win the game
here with an idea so um eric's nodding
does anybody else
see why uh white would be winning yeah
jacob other jacob
uh because you're taking the knight yeah
white's actually able to capture our own
knight here
and this bishop does a really great job
of defending g2
and if we were to push forward king's
just in time to stop this pawn
and i believe this position is is
winning we can just bring our bishop
back
to cover this square bring our king in
and push our pawns
so f3 right away doesn't work but that's
going to be a really really important
idea
and the reason why i'm i like starting
with that
is this is how calculation really works
you find an idea
and then even if it doesn't work right
away you keep that idea in mind
and you try to rework your your
variations to make it
to make it good so who has a better
first move yeah eric yeah king e3
uh king e3 is a good start um
now uh let's say that
white uh just wants to play a4 white's
gonna try
to push forward on the queen side while
you're busy over here
so what becomes our critical variation
so not just f3
but what is
not e4 is bad um so yeah the problem
with 94
is why it's going to take and we stop f3
so f3 is our idea but what's the the
critical variation what's
uh what we have to deal with
i mean i guess
eric needs some time eric needs some
time but he was uh
he was correctly pointing out that our
critical variation isn't really oh
oh my god i've ruined everything
uh our critical variation isn't gonna be
if
uh white takes on f three knight takes
f3 our critical variation isn't g takes
f
because this one's easy we see that that
we're promoting
um and yeah maybe we should update our
lead chess settings so it's not so easy
to resize the board um but okay
our critical variation is going to be
what happens if white just starts
pushing on
the queen's side right this is what we
have to determine we're up a piece but
these pawns look dangerous
so now that we see this critical idea
if i were for example teaching a private
lesson or something something less
in a visual format i would leave this
position on the board and i would say
okay
you've seen the the critical ideas now
calculate it out to the end and see if
you can tell me
the result you know what what's going on
at the end of the variation
now since this is a youtube video and we
are in a
visual format i'm going to give you a
couple more moves so let's say f3
takes takes and a5 we get to this
position
now how do we continue from here
take a moment again take a moment
and in classic fashion the chat is
giving me one move at a time
i know you know the next move but the
question is what's the move after that
and the move after that and the move
after that
so we have two main options here who can
tell me the the two main options
that we have to calculate
yeah jacob
yeah so option number one is to take a
slower approach
we bring the knight back and try to stop
these two pawns in their tracks
and so this is probably fine but we have
to think about it more
and then what's our other option that we
can try not saying it works
but what's the other the other try yeah
brian
yeah if we can play king f2 and make a
queen maybe that's something we should
think about
right so uh has anyone
finished calculating either of these
options yet or does anyone think they
finish
okay so knight h4 is the same idea as
king f2 basically right you just want to
take this pawn
and promote but i think it might be a
move or two slower um
but yeah basically the same idea as king
f2
all right i'm thinking eric d4
is the right move because you're
like a white's king guys is going to go
from e1
to the corner because if they try to go
well first of all they can't go anywhere
else so like
i assume some sort of ponder is going to
happen and i'll just play knight e5 and
then
white is stuck and my idea is to just
keep on like
keep on repeating night moves until the
king has to go to f1
and then i play king v2 and then force
it more and more to the corner
and then i make it so that
all right so eric has
eric's gotten pretty far he's not quite
to the end yet from what i'm hearing
um he's gotten to a point where he says
and then there's some kind of heroic
night maneuver
to win the game which is fair enough
fair enough but
um yeah he's saying he thinks knight d4
is correct and he has some idea
so i assume he's going to think more
about that idea to try and give me the
concrete stuff
but he's he thinks he's onto something
with knight d4 um
so the the point i i want to get across
though is we probably should have
calculated king f2 first because king f2
is more forcing
if king of two works then we can be done
right you know we
calculate king of two and we get to the
end but unfortunately for us
it's just not going to work white's
going to be promoting way too soon
and you know worst case you know white's
probably going to try to win this
but white could just like take our pawn
and we're not happy
so that's how we end up with this idea
of knight d4
we just want to stop the pawns in their
tracks let's say a6 knight b5
and then uh focus on trying to win this
pawn some other way
or winning some other way so now we're
at this point
we're at this point so how can we
continue from here well let's say
what we need one more move for white so
who knows what uh what white's next move
is going to be
yeah jacob he's going to play yeah so
king e1
white's not going to give up this pawn
for free he's going to want to try to
stop us
from from invading so now we have to be
clever
come up with something heroic maybe i
also
do knight a7 is going to be your first
move
oh we'll calculate it
and i think the class is strong enough
tonight that
i'm going to ask you to find the winning
idea from here
and we will train our visualization just
a little bit
just a little bit
and i am keeping an eye on our youtube
chat here we've got some ideas
uh
oh and someone in the chat has given me
the last move of the variation which is
much more interesting than the first
move of the variation
so i think someone in the chat might
have uh might have worked it out maybe
they missed a detail here or there
but they've got a got some good ideas
caleb knows the last move he's
all right what do you think the last
move is last move by any chance
very interesting maybe knight f2 is an
idea so
now we just need to work out how eric's
heroic knight maneuver brings the knight
to uh to f2 so to start with everybody's
saying knight a7
i like this okay jacob thinks he has the
whole line so you give it to me and
i'll put it on the board okay seven
first night seven
and then if he plays b4 it doesn't
really matter
so let's say b4 he doesn't want to let
us in so he's going to keep opposition
knight b5 and then if he stacks a7
you're gonna take but if not if he plays
king f1
uh you're gonna play uh king d2 okay
and then always if they said you're
gonna take but then you're gonna play
king q1
you're gonna play key two he's gonna
play king h1
that's
okay i make a queen and then oh wait
oh god oh it's so illegal oh no i'm
trying jacob it just won't let me
you were almost there almost there okay
then you take the monster take this one
take them on first
one now you don't take them out yeah
night 96
knight f2 check me well done everybody
well done
so we can kind of see how this
quote-unquote tactic is wildly different
than the one with all the patterns right
there weren't that many patterns
in this tactic we there were a few there
was the idea of
an advanced pawn trying to promote
there's an idea of this checkmate
pattern
but the the really heavy lifting is this
visualization seeing it ahead of time
calculating out all the moves and so
that's why i like endgame studies
for training this visualization so this
is definitely one way
to do it but i also want to talk about
uh in a little bit here
we'll cover this some more but i want to
talk about
another way to train your visualization
so we'll get to that but first let's
talk a little bit more about this
just because i like this position i have
a question for you guys
let's say a7 was played here right jacob
said we're always going to take if they
play a7
but let's say now they play b5 yeah well
this is the one time you know
no we don't take no no the key is not
there yet we do take
all right how do you win this one
try to you get your knight to age three
after
wailing
yeah so when the king is on age one you
play uh
knight h3
yeah all right eric's got the idea um
he wanted to put the knight onto h3 i i
think f3 is a little bit easier to get
to so we're gonna go with that one
um and so along the way uh let's say
knight d4
king here we can't do it yet because
then he just takes and it's a draw but
our winning idea
is going to be knight f3 or h3 here
and then we get king f2 and we get to
make a queen before they do so just one
more note
on that puzzle um so you know i like
endgame studies they're great for
training visualization
they're not for everybody some people
just can't take these
and a lot of times end game studies uh
while they're good for training
visualization
they'll be very very very difficult
right the endgame studies can be just
enormously difficult with very strange
ideas that feel like they're not going
to show up in your games
and so you can sit there trying to
visualize and calculate for
you know for hours but if that's just
really some strange idea that you're not
able to consider
then it might not be the most useful for
visualization so there's actually
another way that i like to uh to train
it that
is a pretty new idea to me i hadn't seen
this done many other places but we're
going to do something
that are kind of half blindfold tactics
so of course
trying to get better at chess you're not
going to be able to play a blindfold
game until
you're already pretty good but what am i
talking about well let me show you this
position
and so this is going to bring us to one
of the other tools
that's uh that i want to highlight here
tonight
so this is a position from the leeches
daily puzzle today
just to show you can be done with any
puzzle and
uh what happened in this position is
white played queen c7 check
black played king f6 white played queen
f4
check and black played king g7 and so
the trick now is i'm going to ask you to
solve the tactic from that position
so if you're here uh in the live
audience you can see those moves
in the notation if you need a refresher
for the youtube uh chat i'll say it one
more time
white plays queen c7 black plays king f6
white plays queen f4 check black plays
king g7
and then there's a tactic so try and
solve that
tactic in your head from here and this
is the trick to visualizing i'll give
you a little bit of time
yeah these are just random players from
the leeches daily puzzle
today
all right there is a third jacob in the
youtube chat who thinks they have it
their line is pretty convincing
no no no no so these this is what
happens in the game
and then you have to solve the position
after king g7
so after king g7 what's the win for
white
because in this position white's not
even winning in the initial
eric has the answer but we're gonna wait
a little longer
all right any ideas
so one more time we're thinking about
the position after queen c7
king f6 queen f4 king g7
all right go ahead eric
yeah that's exactly right so again
it's not a difficult tactic if you start
from this position
um it's just it's a two move long tactic
three moves in one line
you give this check the king can either
go to the h file or go to f8
it goes to f8 we give queen d6
and rook g8 is checkmate
and if the king goes to the h file
then we get rook h2 pin the queen to the
king and we we're just winning here
um are we just winning yes it may look a
little bit scary because
black has two rooks and many pawns but
the king's weak enough that we're just
going to be winning
in this position so
this is the trick you can see how this
is a lot better for visualization than
doing normal tactics so you do
easier tactics that you would be able to
solve almost instantly
on your own but you do them from a
couple moves away so you have to really
think forward and visualize where the
pieces are going in your head
and it's a great way to train
visualization now it can be a little bit
tedious
to do this manually it can be kind of
tough
if you are using a chest book for
example
it can be useful just to not always
follow along uh on your board but maybe
leave your board a couple moves behind
and try to be thinking about the two
moves
that uh that the author has written just
in your head
but i do have another really useful tool
for you guys
and that comes from leestuddy.org so of
course lead chess is open source
and uh people copy it and make changes
to it all the time
and i believe this is one of those
offshoots they have made a special type
of tactics trainer
called blind tactics so the idea of this
website is exactly what we just did
except the computer sort of does the
work for you so for example it says this
is blind tactic 717
it tells you in this position the
following moves were played
queen takes c7 king h uh king h6
queen d8 and queen e1 and then it asks
you
to find the tactic after that
so i guess we can solve this one
together as well
all right eric thinks he has it
go ahead
yeah that's exactly right so it gets a
little bit it takes a little bit to get
used to but the way you actually solved
the tactic eric said it was
queen back to f8 king g5 queen f4 and
that's exactly right
you just click on the square where the p
should be in this case the queen is
actually there
and then you click on the square where
it should go to so that's the correct
move
it tells you that black played the move
king g5
and now eric's last move is queen f4
checkmate so we click on the f8 square
we click on the f4 square it says
tactics solved
we get to see the final position so
again this is leasestudy.org
if you're interested in checking it out
they have a few different kinds of
things on this website but i really like
this blind tactics trainer it makes it
super easy
to do what we were just uh just going
over so
jumping back to lead chest there's one
more thing that i want to talk about
some people you know they're really
great at this pattern recognition they
have all the patterns
down pat some people are really great at
calculating as well they can visualize
and calculate
so far ahead but for some reason they
still aren't seeing their tactics in
their
games and the reason for that is there's
actually a third step
that's really hard to uh to practice
if you're just doing tactics puzzles
it's knowing when to think about them
you know uh you don't always have time
in your games to be thinking is there a
tactic
on every single turn so how should you
should you practice that well i want to
start with a a puzzle here
this is from my game uh at the last
chicago open
and we're actually not going to be
looking for my perspective we're going
to be looking from
white's perspective here and in this
position
whites believed they might have a tactic
so my question for you is uh how do we
implement
you know this pattern recognition this
visualization
into uh into an actual move
here so all right jacob has something to
say uh what was your opponent's rating
um akash he's a national master i
believe he dipped down to 2150
or so at the time of the game
and the reason why i show you this
position isn't because it's
incredibly difficult or anything it's um
it's
giving you an idea of this problem that
some people have it's more of an
illustration
so who sees a potentially tempting move
for white
it seems like there might be a tactic
right eric
obviously yes so ideas revolving around
knight f6
are kind of floating in the air um and
my opponent actually took it a step
further
my yeah my opponent played this
killer sacrifice rook takes d5 now
uh unfortunately you guys can see the
results of the game which means
that rook d5 maybe wasn't wasn't
advisable i did end up winning this game
and so uh let's turn off our tactics
brain for a little bit and think about
this position who would you rather be
black or white
yeah white white white is significantly
better
he has the catalan bishop i lost my
catalan bishop to unforeseen
circumstances and so white just has a
lot of pressure on the light squares
and if he had played a simple move like
knight c3 just keeping up the pressure
here on this diagonal
using his more active pieces black would
be significantly worse i would be much
much worse in this position
because this bishop's just super strong
now losing maybe not but
significantly worse instead he goes for
this slightly risky tactic
i take back he goes knight f6 check king
g7
and knight takes d5 and now
i came up with the move rook d6 and
after rook d6 black is
is actually doing fine um there's some
more tactics you have to kind of
calculate through
but uh just take my word for it rook d6
and black is
is doing okay here and after the game my
opponent told me yeah
i just missed rook d6 um but that's sort
of missing the point
uh white should never really be playing
rook takes d5
unless he's absolutely certain that it's
just a tactical knockout that he just is
completely winning at the end of it
because in your games uh it's much much
better
to take an easy advantage uh when you
know you have an easy advantage
than a very complicated tactical
position where you think you're you're
better but but you're not
entirely sure so that was my opponent's
mistake
not only yes he miscalculated a little
bit he missed rook d6
um but the mistake was in his thinking
right no amount of tactics puzzles
would have solved this uh this problem
for him
so how do you train this this sort of
concept of how do i apply tactics to
games
who thinks they have an idea for how to
uh to train this part
of their tactical thinking all right
eric has an idea
playing more chess is eric's idea always
a good always a good way
to train but let's say you hate playing
chess and you just want to study chess
all day
no not the woodpecker method that's just
going to give you the this pattern
recognition maybe
train your calculation a little bit but
yeah
i don't know how to actually implement
this but it would be nice if you could
just
be given a position and try to guess
like
who's better and by how much and then
because if white understood that they
were much better here then they
yeah um so yeah training
uh your ability to evaluate a position
is
something that brian was talking about i
don't know a good trainer for that
but uh for this specific idea of how do
tactics
fit their way into normal games honestly
i think the best thing you can do
is play guess the move so who's played
guess the move before
with uh with the game jacob's done it
eric's done it
um so what is guess the move well it's a
really easy game to play um the best way
that i've found to do it is to
get a book games a collection of games
that are annotated
and you go move by move you pick a color
and you say
okay i'm gonna play white in this
position what do i think the best move
is
uh and you just go through the game move
by move you guess the move at every turn
you see where you are differing from uh
the grand master and you uh
you see where your thoughts are
differing and after the game after you
finish it you go back through maybe with
a computer
and you sort of check your work now i
was gonna play a game of guess the move
with you here tonight but i think we're
a little bit too short on time
to do that with just a couple minutes
left in the game but this
is sort of the the big thing that puts
all the pieces together
you're going to be calculating as if you
were in a real game if you're playing
along
trying to guess the moves and it's going
to show you when the gm
decides to to go for more tactics and
when they're saying
you know i just have a nice advantage
with this move and they they play this
other one
so you can do this with unannotated
games just following along with a
professional tournament
but if you do it with games that are
annotated where the thoughts are sort of
explained
it's even more helpful because you don't
have to guess oh well
i guess they didn't go for the tactic
because they liked their position a lot
of times they just tell you they just
say
yeah i played knight c3 here because my
position was good
and rotates d5 looked messy um
okay so that is all i have for tonight
then are there any final questions
on the tactical ideas we talked about
tonight
any questions at all eric has a question
about this position
yeah specifically uh after rookie six
in the game um
yeah so these are the messy tactics that
i told you to trust me on eric was
asking what happens if queen c3
and knight b4 and the messy tactic is
knight d4
so i i have this idea to unpin and fork
the the king and the queen
um importantly uh after night before
here i i also have knight d4
and queen c3 i only have one move in
this position
if you want to try to find it
of course f6 ben feingold's in shambles
f6 unpinning the knight and now knight
e2 is going to to be the same line
um any other questions for me before we
get out of here and we turn it over to
grandmaster lazaro bruzon for his
inaugural youtube class
potentially maybe not might be offline
this
today
all right yes i am i didn't say the
thing i'm i'm kayla i'm your driver on
this journey there we go we got it into
the end of the video
um all right well thank you all so much
for joining me here tonight for our
first ever
dual in-person online class it's a lot
of fun to be back in the classroom
hopefully you guys online are enjoying
as well
and as always i will see you guys next
time
[Music]
you